my friend jessie waters has gotten in
trouble recently
because jesse waters is a
show tv show host at fox news jesse
waters was speaking at the turning point
usa conference a week or so ago
and
jesse
uh got in trouble because the left-wing
media said he threatened to kill
dr fauci he threatened he encouraged
people to go out there and shoot dr
fauci in the head uh when i read that i
i thought you know i don't look
i'm not saying that jesse waters and i
are bosom buddies but i know the guy a
little bit i don't i don't think he's
the sort of fella to do that
that said let me
let me go find the speech and you'll
notice that all the left-wing networks
that are that are pushing this
none of them are showing you the actual
speech so i thought okay there's the
dead giveaway he didn't really say that
take a listen to what jesse waters
actually said
you gotta ambush a guy like fauci okay
this is how you do these ambushes like
o'keefe
you got to be respectful
because they'll turn the tables on you
and you can't have a blow up in your
face so if you see fouchy out and about
and you know he's coming to town this is
how you approach okay
keep a little document in your pocket
all right
this is the grant
that funded the research it's in your
pocket not even rand paul has been able
to get in his face and point with the
grant in his face
so then he's in trouble
now you're going for the kill shot
the kill shot
with an ambush
deadly
because he doesn't see it coming
this is when you say
dr fauci
you funded
risky research at a sloppy chinese lab
the same lab that sprung this pandemic
on the world
you know why people don't trust you
don't you
boom he is dead
okay does anyone watching that clip
believe that jesse waters is encouraging
people to go out and shoot dr fauci in
the head
no he's obviously speaking rhetorically
he's obviously speaking metaphorically
right he's saying are you saying here's
here's the ambush
the ambush is not throwing a net on him
or tackling him the ambush is hey i've
got this document and then here's the
kill shot the kill shot is not a bullet
to the head the kill shot is
you funded this risky research at a
filthy chinese laboratory that then had
a virus escape and okay fair enough
well the left is going bonkers with this
they think this is an opportunity to
take out
a conservative tv host and so
not only is cnn talking about how awful
this is not only are the left-wing media
dr fauci himself is saying jesse waters
should be fired
dr fauci dr fauci
is
horrified by the suggestion made by
jesse waters that people should confront
him over his funding of the wuhan
research facility
and so dr fatchi says jesse waters needs
to get fired
well john that's horrible i mean that
just is such a reflection of the
craziness that goes on in society the
only thing that i have ever done
throughout these two years is to
encourage people to practice good public
health practices to get vaccinated to be
careful in public settings to wear a
mask and for that you have some guy out
there saying that people should be
giving me a kill shot to ambush me i
mean what kind of craziness is there in
society these days that's awful that he
said that and he's going to go very
likely
unaccountable i mean whatever network
he's on is not going to do anything for
him i mean that's crazy the guy should
be fired on the spot
should be fired on the spot there's only
one person in this situation who should
be fired on the spot who should have
been fired on the spot a very long time
ago that would be the guy who has run
the infectious diseases branch of nih
for seven presidents
the guy who screwed up aids who engaged
in extremely risky
illegal at one point research in into
game of function research and then who
screwed up the entire response to the
pandemic that would be dr anthony fauci
he should be fired he should be fired he
should very likely be prosecuted at
least for perjury don't forget he
perjured himself while he was testifying
before the senate he said that he didn't
fund game of function research and he
did and we have all the evidence that he
did
and
he should be banished to saint helen
okay i know people are going to say
that's too far no
fired for sure
prosecuted for sure
banished to a far-flung island where he
can never exert his terrible political
influence again
probably at least i'm all for it that
might be a harder pitch to some people
but i'm all for it and as fauxci
predicted fox news is sticking by jesse
waters i think that's great
i think it's really great that fox news
is sticking by one of their on-air
personalities when uh his comments were
taken completely out of context by
leftist
democrat operatives i think that's
really good that's good to see
maybe a little surprising these days but
it's good to see i'm glad i'm glad that
fox did that
so good job good job fox that's great
glad that jesse waters is going to make
it i'm glad you like that clip
it was one of my favorite clips it was
so i'm glad that you liked i'm glad we
have similar tastes
you gotta ring the bell subscribe and
head on over to apple podcast spotify
stitcher google play wherever you get
your audio podcast subscribe to the
michael knowles show leave a five star
review if you wouldn't mind we'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you